notre position est claire ce report de
l'âge légal nous estimons indispensable
pour sauver le système par répartition
bon les débats avance nous avons enfin
cette nous une gauche qui multiplie
toutes les formes d'obstructions en le
faisant pas comment l'Assemblée
nationale en respectant le Sénat d'un la
dignité des débats on a d'ailleurs de
temps en temps de débat donc en termes
de dignité le Sénat travail nous
arrivons à l'article 6 après une nuit de
séance Président
je trouve d'abord de l'utilité du Sénat
pour aller au fond et ensuite pour ce
qui concerne le vote de ce texte nous le
voterons parce qu'il est largement sur
nos positions nous n'avons pas rallié
monsieur Macron c'est Monsieur Macron
qui est venu reprendre ce qui était
l'opposition c'est pas parce que
Monsieur Macron dit qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui que nous allons dire qu'il
pleut s'il fait beau aujourd'hui voilà
mais par contre ce nous allons continuer
de textes de mettre des marqueurs qui
sont nos convictions vous savez on ne
perd jamais à rester sur ses convictions
comme le dit le président Retailleau
alors aujourd'hui je j'entends bien le
pays je vois bien qu'il y a de
l'incompréhension c'était compréhension
si le gouvernement qui est responsable
parce que certaines demandes que tout
cela manquait de pédagogie
d'explications de dialogues de
constatation quand on voit que la cet
été monsieur berger sont dans un franc
syndical avec la CGT c'est soleil qu'on
peut bien gouvernement mais nous avons
beaucoup travaillé en amont
nous n'allons pas répondre à la
provocation monsieur dossu et les
groupes d'opposition voudrait tellement
que nous on entre dans la mise en scène
qu'ils auraient eux-mêmes décidés
ils ne sont pas de mettre des horloges
ils ne sont pas des maîtres de la
scénographie du Sénat le Sénat travaille
sous la houlette de du président de
l'archet qui préside lui-même et donc en
effet Monsieur on a bien senti depuis
vendredi que les natrices sénateurs
d'opposition trépide parce que nous
rentrons pas dans leur jeu nous n'avons
qu'une envie de rentrer dans leur jeu
parce que leur jeu est relativement
grossi alors l'obstruction n'a pas les
formes très désagréables très
insupportables qui étaient indignes par
rapport à la démocratie parlementaire
qui ont la France insoumise a fait peser
sur l'Assemblée nationale c'est une
obstruction plus digne du Sénat mais ça
reste d'obstruction et nous on n'est pas
obligé de rentrer dans le jeu de
Monsieur dossier
attention là qu'est-ce que vous êtes
vous allez prendre des décisions
aujourd'hui pour accélérer le
développement je pense à s'accélère tout
seul vous savez la nuit les amendements
tombent tout seul parce qu'ils sont pas
toujours soutenus on sera aussi
l'autorité du président lâcher qui fait
que les procédures lorsqu'elles sont
trop grossières certaines sénateurs et
je les en remercie ne les pratiquent pas
parce qu'ils respectent l'autorité
naturelle et le charisme du président
Larcher aujourd'hui on peut je pense
surtout après la journée que nous aurons
connus de mobilisation que je respecte
par ailleurs le droit de grève est
constitutionnel le droit de
manifestation est constitutionnel le
droit de blocage ne n'est pas
quotidienne parce qu'il est heurté un
autre droit constitutionnel celui de la
liberté de circuler de la liberté
d'aller travailler si on a envie mais je
respecte le mouvement social mais après
je pense cette journée du 7 parce que
nous allons accélérer le rythme je
souhaite nous souhaitons aller jusqu'au
bout du texte parce qu'après l'article 7
dont on parle il y a des articles
importants sur la pénibilité sur le
travail du seniors sur le femme dans le
système dans le système de retard bref
sur tout ce qui fait un système de
répartition qui est un système de
solidarité qui est un système
démographique et notre volonté à travers
ce vote de cette droite et la mue
représente cette loi c'est de sauver un
système de répartition et cela passe par
des postures qui ne sont pas obligés
politicienne mais c'est nous les avons
un petit peu subi tu veux vendredi
mais si
si ma partie ou pas je ne suis ni
président ni président du sida la partie
au président du Sénat de faire en sorte
que la volonté de la majorité des
sénateurs et du président d'archiver
d'ailleurs d'aller jusqu'au bout du
texte de faire son travail de
parlementaire de ne pas tomber dans la
caricature qui a décidé
enjeu au-delà du système de retraite par
répartition c'est la démocratie
parlementaire donc s'il faut utiliser
des articles qui limitent le temps
d'expression qui donne un peu plus de
contraintes à l'expression pour
l'instant le président lâcher de l'a pas
fait des débat avance s'il faut le faire
le président l'archet le fera mais ça a
dû appartient ce ne suis pas au plateau
lui seul est au plateau il le fait
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de dextérité
[Musique]